Hello.
Hello and welcome to the Rubin report. Direct message. I'm your host,
Dave Rubin. It's December 18th, 2020.
And I'm pretending that I'm a network news anchor. How am I doing?
I feel pretty good. All right, guys,
this is our last live direct message of
2020 that's right.
I'm giving my guys off for the remainder of the year.
We've got a bunch of best of shows coming out over the next 10 days or so.
And I'll be at turning point student action summit in Florida giving a talk
on Monday, which we're going to post that talk.
I'll be in front of live human beings. My God,
what a world I haven't been in front of live human beings,
at least giving a talk in front of a whole bunch of them while holding a
microphone, uh, since literally one year ago at this very same event.
So I'm super psyched to be doing that. Uh,
but my guys have been busting their butts, working really hard all year.
The team has expanded in the midst of lockdown.
Actually the two guys that I have in studio right now,
now not to get Garcetti looking at me like I have people in my room right now,
but, but Michael and Connor, uh, both our new hires this year.
So our team has expanded and everybody's worked incredibly hard, you know,
doing stuff remote and now, uh, in a new studio, right?
We started another studio this year, like just so many things.
So I want my guys to enjoy the Christmas break and the end of the year.
And actually one of the things that I write about in Dover in this book is that
if you're ever going to take just a week off of social media,
that Christmas week basically rolling into the new years,
like that's kind of the time to do it right. To focus on food, family,
friends, remember those things. Uh, so that's what I'm mostly going to be doing.
I'm really going to limit all my social media stuff.
I'm going to be posting on the Rubin report community.
So if you want to join us there,
I can have a little more actually human interaction with you guys there.
And as I said, we'll post a couple of videos, but really,
I just want people to kind of enjoy the end of the year. So that,
that is my goal. Uh, it's been a busy day already though, and I've,
I've got a busy day ahead. So we're, we're ended strong.
I was on outnumbered on Fox, uh, this morning already.
I think that was at 9:00 AM. Was I on at 9:00 AM? And, uh,
it's four lady hosts and they bring in a guy. I was the guy, uh,
this morning and that, that was fun. And then I'm on, uh,
with Martha MacCallum a little bit later this afternoon,
and we're going to hit a couple of stories here and, uh, then you know,
you'll go about your way. You know what I mean? Simple as that, Oh, by the way,
I do have my trusty glasses today because I may have to give a special
message for somebody. Oh, and one other thing before we get to, uh,
to the main meat of the show today, uh, you know, I talked about, uh,
having alopecia areata yesterday and I showed some pictures of,
at one point I had lost probably about 40% of my hair.
I went under these horrible experimental treatments and just awful, awful stuff.
And I just want to say, I got so many freaking messages yesterday from,
from many of you who not only have dealt with alopecia, uh,
but have dealt with just like all sorts of strange auto-immune diseases that you
chalk up to stress that in many cases,
doctors couldn't figure out exactly why you were breaking out in hives or having
other kinds of skin problems or alopecia or whatever it is. Uh,
and I just want to say,
that's exactly why I try to do this show the way I do it.
Because as I always tell you, I'm not trying to make you crazy.
I'm not trying to make you nervous or frantic or psychotic or tense or
any of those things. Like I'm trying to do this stuff in a, in a palatable way.
Uh, but it's also why I started doing the August off the grid thing,
uh, where I take the month off August.
It's why I think shutting it down as we roll into Christmas and new year,
I think is important. And I hope you guys are just taking care of yourselves.
However you see fit. Uh, but speaking of taking care of yourselves,
we have governors in this wonderful country, democratic governors,
people like Andrew Cuomo in New York and Gavin Newsome in
California and Gretchen Whitmer in Michigan.
And if you don't remember Gretchen Whitmer, she is the woman who,
after a couple of weeks of lockdown,
she announced that people in Michigan should not do gardening and
landscaping outside of their homes, meaning on your own property.
She was trying to get people to stop planting plants. Okay.
Literally trying to stop people, planting plants. You may not remember this,
but I actually sent seeds to people in Michigan.
We did a little thing on Twitter and I sent seed. So people could plant tomato,
plants, cucumbers. I think we sent a, what else did we send?
We send some Brussels sprouts.
Somebody told me they didn't want Brussels sprouts,
which made me send it to them. Cause I was like, you know, if you can't,
you know, I'm moving seeds here. You're going to take what you can get. Anyway,
the point is, she's a ridiculous authoritarian lockdown,
ho and a locked down. Oh, I like that one.
Um, but of course she doesn't abide by her own rules.
In the midst of the lockdown she was seen, uh, on,
I believe it was on her boat or a friend's boat for her husband's birthday party
with a whole bunch of friends, no social distancing and the rest of it.
Of course the hypocrisy known knows no bounds.
You guys know how all of them flaunt their rules and make you the
peons, uh, live under their boot? Uh, well, Gretchen Whitmer,
uh, she did a zoom with some children from Michigan and, uh,
and Santa Claus. So I don't know how she got ahold of Santa Claus.
He's very busy this time of year, but here is governor Gretchen,
Whitmer Santa Claus and the children of Michigan.
Thank you for joining us.
I'm governor Gretchen Whitmer and I'm really excited
to be here with all of you.
And I also know someone who's been really following the
rules and making sure that he stays safe and the elves stay
safe. And so my special guest is Santa Claus. Hello,
boys and girls. How are you?
Does anyone have a question for Santa Claus? Cinda?
Do you have to wear a mask?
I'm in my workshop with all my ELLs,
we all are mashed up in social distancing.
How SAC?
Yes, please do carrots and cookies. If you can.
That was a good suggestion.
Everyone has been testing negative. We're still getting tested.
I think we're so far up North that it might not be getting to us,
but are not going to take any chances. We're all gonna mask up.
We're all gonna launch our hands and we're all going to stay
six feet apart.
How can we keep people safe for Christmas?
What I would suggest to do,
just let the governor is telling all the people of the great state of Michigan
to do social distance,
wash your hands and make sure you wear your
mask when you're outside your home.
And another way to stay safe during the holiday is to stay
home,
but call your grandparents and your cousins and your family.
And it's the safest way to tell the people you love,
how much you care about them this year.
It has to look a little bit different so we can stay safe.
And I appreciate all of you doing your part.
Phanta thank you so much for making time for us today. Let's hear your boss.
Oh,
hi everybody.
Oh, excuse me. I was vomiting that entire time.
I don't like you Gretchen Whitmer that whole thing was so absolutely
staggeringly nauseated.
Okay. There's so much there. The first question,
the first question that a child has for Santa Santa's,
do you have to wear a mask? That's what the first question was Santa,
can I have a train Santa? Can I have a shotgun Santa?
Can I have a new governor? Those things, all would've made sense, Santa,
do you have to wear a mask? Um, then he,
you see this moment where he tells them that all have to stand six feet away
from each other. And then a whole bunch of kids who are all together,
probably about 10 kids at a [inaudible]
it, this is such ridiculous propaganda and training
children to be obedient,
pets by adults who won't even behave by their own
rules.
If you think for even one moment that Gretchen
Whitmer is going to spend Christmas six feet away from
everybody, not with anyone from her home or obeying the rest of the
lockdown orders,
that she would wish that these children's parents would live under.
You got another thing coming. And you know,
I haven't busted out the old newsman glasses in a while, right?
I've busted them out.
I've talked about bill de Blasio special message to Andrew Cuomo,
special message to Eric,
our SETI special message to Gavin Newsome.
But I haven't busted them out in a while. And people have said,
a lot of people have said, Dave, we wish you would bust the glasses out more.
It's a very important message. You,
we put the glasses on and you take them off and you talk directly to the camera
and you lay out a message for these people.
I haven't done it because it's the holiday season. And I've been trying to,
you know, not curse as much and everything else, but I just, here we are.
And it's just, you know.
Gretchen Whitmer.
Merry Christmas. Could you be a little bit better? I should've said it.
I should've said it now. I was trying to be nice. I'm trying to be nice here.
You see what they've done as a, as a general rule. I'm a,
I'm a pretty nice guy and they've put me in a position of not only am I
now a radical freedom extremist,
but then I'm also saying these words every now and again. All right.
So that was graduating. America's I'll just
Michigan governor Gretchen, Whitmer.
Go yourself.
Joking aside. This is just serious drivel.
Like this sort of training of children.
It's so dangerous and this has nothing to do with what the
government is supposed to do, right? Like this isn't,
the government is supposed to protect life, Liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness. It's just supposed to put the guard rails there.
So we're not killing each other out on the streets, that's it.
And it's supposed to get out of our way,
the idea that we're looking to these people as our role models,
or as people who should be telling us what to do and when to do it and who we
can be with and what we can eat and when we can eat where we can go and all of
these things, it's just absolutely crazy. And I, I hope that if nothing else,
if you do nothing else during Christmas, you,
you spend the time with your loved ones and people that you want to be with and
friends and family and all that, and ignore these silly, silly people.
But let's talk a little bit more about lockdowns because I've been saying
something for a couple of weeks here that now I see bubbling up all over
mainstream media. Tucker was talking about it last night on Fox news,
Tucker Carlson, of course,
and a whole bunch of other people have been bringing it up.
I hadn't heard anyone saying it.
And then I've said it a couple of times over the last few weeks.
And I think I mentioned it, uh, uh, on Newsmax and maybe on Fox,
but one of the very odd things to me about these lockdowns that we're told are
so important is that here in California, we've been under a perpetual lockdown.
Everyone's wearing a mask everywhere. Yes, I did. Uh, you know, may a Copa guys.
I walked the dog this morning and I had an illegal haircut yesterday. I know,
I know I'm a radical, what can I tell you? But,
but what seems odd to me is if, if these lockdowns work well,
I am in the most lockdown state here in California, Florida is open.
Texas is basically open shouldn't their numbers be
double, triple exponentially, larger, right?
Exponentially, more than the numbers in the lockdown States.
If any of this made sense, now not everything is apples to apples.
California has a ton of people. There's weather, things that are different,
but also you could look at Florida, which has an extremely elderly population.
I mean, there there's all sorts of factors,
but the point is that if lockdown as a general rule worked,
wouldn't we see that lockdown States would be going down and open States
would be going up. And in fact,
we see the reverse and it's partly because we're not letting these States that
are locked down, hit herd immunity, and a series of other things.
So the Federalist did an interesting piece on this and, uh,
here's what they said thus far in Florida,
approximately 20,000 people have died of COVID-19 in Texas.
The numbers stands around 24,000 and in New York,
around 35,000, New York is the smallest of the three.
So it's the smallest of those three States.
And it has the most numbers with 19.5,
4 million residents then comes Florida with 21.67
before Texas with 28.7 million restaurants
that have residents, not restaurants. There were no restaurants left anymore.
Uh, the reason that I said restaurants is because, uh,
we also got an interesting number here, uh, that according to New York state.
1.4 0.1 0.4,
3%.
Of Corona cases in New York have been linked to restaurants.
So really think about this for a moment. We are telling people,
stay out of restaurants, not even outdoor restaurants, sorry,
you built all that outdoor space, which isn't cheap.
And isn't easy to do when you're already hurting financially.
You can't go to restaurants,
even though only roughly 1% of the cases have anything to do with restaurants.
We're going to send you back home where then they showed according to their
numbers.
People are getting more infected at home because around family and friends and
everything else again,
which I think you should be allowed to do it as well within your right.
And you should figure out what works for you and your family.
And if you have elderly people, they're infirmed people or everything else,
there's no such thing as a perfect system.
They can't keep you perfectly safe from an a morphous virus that
eight months ago, we were told two weeks to flatten the curve.
And then I watched the infallible Fowchee. That's my new name for him,
the infallible Fowchee, uh, who should really just be a magician. Doesn't it,
it sounds like a Madrid, but you know,
now the infallible Fowchee who will slice this woman in half,
I saw him this morning and he's talking about how, uh, by April,
after we have further lockdowns and more masks and everything else by April,
we can start thinking about getting back to normalcy.
Even though now the vaccines are being taken.
I have a friend in, uh, in Texas, you know who you are, uh, who's a doctor,
frontline worker, and he got the vaccine today.
It is up to you in your own personal life.
And with the choices that you think are appropriate for you to figure out if you
want to take the vaccine or not. Okay. I mean, it's just,
it's just as simple as that, but, but getting to those earlier numbers,
New York has a smaller population than Florida or Texas.
Not everything is equal. I get that. Um,
but clearly the lockdowns don't work.
There's no science behind it. Uh,
yesterday we did the story out of San Diego where a judge looked at the science,
he looked at the science and he said, guess what?
We got to open up the strip clubs.
Cause there's no science to say these things can be, uh, should be closed. Okay.
So we're really getting to this sort of breaking point where some States are
going to be free and some States are not going to be free.
And speaking of free States, as I said at the top of the show,
I'm heading out this weekend to Florida, I'm going to go see what free people.
I feel like I'm going to another country. I mean,
we've really reduced this lunacy that I feel like when I go to Florida,
which I've been to many, many times, and I've always liked Florida.
And I don't mind the humidity, uh, that I'm going to be in another country.
I'm going to get off the plane and I'm going to see people and they might be
hugging each other or talking to each other.
And I might go to a restaurant and order French fries. I don't know.
Maybe I'll have a burger or a steak who knows? Well, it's Florida, right?
I have a lot of fish. I like fresh fish. And I'm going to have that in Florida.
And you can't stop me Gretchen Whitmer Andrew Cuomo or Gavin Newsome.
Anyway, it's all just silly nonsense. Uh,
let's just do one other story on,
uh COVID before I wrap up our last live stream of the year, uh,
you guys may remember the newspaper formerly known as the New York times.
It was once thought of as the paper of record in the United States.
And really now, if you have a bird parakeet, whatever, it might be,
the really the best thing you could use the New York times for is to lie in the
cage. It really has no other purpose besides that. I suppose,
if you were doing papier-mache, do people still do that?
Whatever you do with papier-mache and you can create some sort of sculpture or
something you could the New York times for that.
But the New York times is a crap factory of fake news and drivel.
They've called me all right. They've written,
hit pieces around a ton of people that I know we,
we know they constantly lie about anyone. That's a conservative and they,
they cover the crimes and dribble that that comes out
of the progressive left. They've completely wholly embraced, uh,
identity politics,
a moderate liberal like Barry Weiss had to resign from the
New York times because it has become such a cancerous awful organization. Uh,
I know a couple other people that are loosely affiliated with the New York
times. Some of them that are actually there, uh, that,
that are constantly talking about how horrible it is.
So the New York times is a, organization,
and it it's indicative of how the news and mainstream media has just
absolutely crumbled. Well,
they did a piece this morning and the title of the article in the New York times
is the elderly versus essential workers who should get the first,
who should get currently. Let me start that again.
The elderly versus essential workers who should get the Corona,
no virus vaccine. First. Now that's an interesting title for an article.
And there's an interesting,
I would say moral and ethical debate about who should get the vaccine first,
right?
We've got frontline workers and bus drivers and delivery people and doctors and
nurses and everything else we've got, you know,
who generally are younger and they're putting themselves out there.
So they're more at risk,
but they might have stronger defenses against it and everything else.
So maybe we do that and get it to them first. Maybe we don't.
Then we have elderly people who we know are dying at a higher rate and are more
at risk. So maybe we want to do it there.
And we have to figure out where resources go, great, moral and ethical debate,
right? But here's how the New York times framed it. This is just so spectacular.
Quote, Harold Schmidt,
an expert in ethics and health policy at the university of Pennsylvania
said that it is reasonable to put essential workers ahead of older
adults given their risks. And now here's where it gets good.
And that they are disproportionately minorities.
Older populations are wider. Dr. Schmidt said,
society is structured in a way that enables them to live longer.
Instead of giving additional health benefits to those who already had
more of them, we can start to level the playing field a bit.
Did you catch what he just said there?
Did you catch what Schmidt just said there? I can tell you this, uh,
ethics and what they used to be.
And I don't know what the hell is going on at university of Pennsylvania.
In essence, he is saying,
because some frontline workers who happen to be minorities,
we should let grandma and grandpa Whitey, right? Old, white people,
they should just die. You see how,
what he framed there is so different than what I framed before that if you want
to have the ethical debate about frontline workers versus older people and how
to figure out resources, well, that's just fine.
But once you put color ethnicity into the mix
level, the playing field,
that is the most dangerous phrase that I've ever heard related to all of
this, because what he means is yeah, more of them should die.
More white people should die. And by the way,
if you're thinking that this is shocking,
this is just the end of what identity politics is.
Identity politics is not about raising certain people based on skin color.
It's about taking down other people.
And it literally the end of identity politics is either killing Whitey,
grandma and grandpa, or having laws that will be against white people.
It really is. As simple as that, it is as simple as that.
If you take this thing to its logical conclusion,
and I'd like to give a special shout out to you, losers at media matters,
who are undoubtedly watching this and going to selectively clip what I just said
there, but that is the truth. Uh, they go on to say in the article still,
or he goes on to say, still,
some people believe it is wrong to give racial and
socioeconomic equity more weight than who is most likely to
die. Holy balls, man. You're a horrible person.
Harold Schmidt, university of Pennsylvania should be absolutely embarrassed.
And you, you have no understanding of ethics. Yes.
Who will die,
should absolutely have more weight than the racial and
socioeconomic equity of a group of people.
Right.
Okay. You get it guys, you get it. This is, this is what we're fighting. And,
uh, as I, as I wrap this last direct message of 2020, uh,
let me just say that this is going to continue.
This stuff is going to continue because it has to get to whatever it's
awful sort of horrific rock. Bottom thing is,
and it just isn't there yet. And that I think is the unanswered question.
And maybe that will be the question of 2021.
Maybe the real question of 2021 is now that wokeness has just burst
forth into the disgusting grotesque, anti American anti freedom.
Anti-capitalist thing that it is now that more people get it instead of just the
fringe YouTubers and you crazy people who watch us instead of that,
uh, maybe now that more people see it, it eventually will get,
it will destroy so much. That is good.
It will destroy company's ability to hire qualified people. It will,
it will harm every governmental agency because we'll be hiring transportation
secretaries because they're gay rather than they know what they're doing.
And the litany of other things that you guys know about, right.
That I don't have to talk ad nauseum about.
Maybe 21 will be the year that it all comes crashing down on itself.
I actually felt that 2020 could have been that year,
but then COVID complicated things in a way that obviously nobody fully
understood. Um, alright on that note folks, uh,
this was officially my last in studio live stream for 2020.
I have told my guys, you're not going to believe this guys.
I have here an electronic telephone with a video camera on it.
And, uh, over the course of the next 10 days,
I will maybe I'll do some live streams. I may do some random ones. Uh,
maybe from the beach, walking down the beach,
I'm going to be in Florida trying to enjoy myself, maybe eating some nice,
fresh fish who knows. Uh,
but I will be spending all of my social media time on the Rubin report
community. So you can go to Rubin report.com if you want to join. And,
and we can share thoughts and share food and recipes and music and all
the other pictures of family and all that good stuff.
And I really do love connecting with you guys. A reminder though,
we do have one more sit-down for the year. Uh,
my last interview of the year is with Adam Carolla,
where we're going to just recap everything that happened in 2020 he's on that
short list that I always talk about of sane people. Uh,
so we will recap the craziest year of my lifetime and one of the craziest
years in American history, by the way,
part three of my interview with Abigail Shrier,
all about the sudden burst of trans of young
girls who are transitioning, uh,
that's up right now on YouTube and the full part, uh,
the full interview I should say is@rubinreport.com.
And then we've got a couple year-end compilations.
One is just all my appearances on other shows. And then the other is, uh,
interviews that I did here.
That's that's pretty much it that's pretty much it.
So my final message to you guys, if, uh, as my,
as we shut down here is, uh, love each other.
Love your families be with your families and your friends.
I know it can be tough. I've got versions of it myself,
as I keep telling you guys, um, try to cool it on the, on the political thing.
Uh, during this time of year,
it's like we got a lot to be thankful for and a Merry Christmas to you
guys. Last day of Hanukkah. Technically last night was the last candle,
but I guess it rolls into sundown today. Uh,
and I look forward to seeing you guys in Florida.
I will be at turning point student action summit on Monday,
I'll be doing a couple interviews and, uh, we'll see what else happens. So, Oh,
and just more than anything else, just this,
thank you guys for being part of this adventure this year. I mean,
what a wacky year we have all had and everyone, it, everyone, you know,
there were two ways to end this year, right?
You either kind of went completely nuts or, or you lined some things up in life,
right? Like you started like figuring things out or you just sort of went,
went down with the ship. And, uh, and I'm proud to say that.
I think we've done something really good here. You know, we launched this show.
I wasn't even doing this show at the beginning of the year.
We just launched this show in September. As I said, the team has expanded. Uh,
locals is absolutely crushing it. I think we're,
we're fighting big tech in a really effective, good way. And, uh,
I'm just proud of what's going on. And it's all because of you guys.
So thank you guys. Merry Christmas, happy new year. And.
I'll see ya in 2021.